c'est dans un hôpital comme celui ci à
edmonton qu'ils ont été envoyées ou
plutôt séquestré bonne ambiance de noël
dans ce reportage de l'époque
mais cela reste un cauchemar pour les
quelques 5000 inuit qu'ils ont vécu et
leurs proches
avec dans le rôle du méchant le
gouvernement fédéral
[Musique]
justin trudeau est venu leur présenter
des excuses des excuses officielles pour
la gestion que le gouvernement fédéral a
fait de l'épidémie de tuberculose
entre 1940 et 1960
cette politique n'était pas accidentel
mais bien intentionnelle la gestion dont
parle justin trudeau
c'était d'embarquer les malades sur un
navire et de les emmener dans des
sanatoriums loin de chez eux pendant des
mois
les années passent on leur a ordonné de
rester couché ont testé des électrochocs
et quand ils étaient renvoyés chez eux
c'était parfois dans la mauvaise
communauté environ 900 serait mort et
enterré dans un endroit inconnu de leur
famille
des excuses qui y ont une fonction très
précises ce que ça dit en fait
aujourd'hui au peuple inuit c'est que
pendant toutes ces années il avait
raison de trouver le traitement que leur
a été infligée injuste inhumain
discriminatoire voire même raciste mais
s'excuser ce n'est pas assez un registre
a été ouvert pour tenter de retrouver la
trace des disparus et le gouvernement
s'est engagé à éradiquer la tuberculose
d'ici 2030 au nunavut
il ya encore aujourd'hui 300 fois plus
de risques de contracter la maladie
qu'ailleurs au canada
les maisons quand est annoncé
aujourd'hui à apporte très certainement
un bon aux communautés inuit ça c'est
certain mais ça veut pas dire que parce
que vous avez vous apporté un bon
cocktail est en mesure de rétablir des
relations de confiance qui ont été
brisés depuis plus de 200 ans
et selon lui le canada n'est pas encore
sorti de sa relation paternaliste avec
les peuples autochtones
ici mathieu prost radio-canada mont
royal